moments after getting endorsed for
Democrats fleeing this slow-rolling
disaster
Joe Biden quickly inspired confidence in
their decision we all these truths to be
self-evident all men are women created
by goal you know that you know the thing
look tomorrow Superstar Susie and I want
to thank you all I tell you what I'm
rushing ahead aren't I
as always blame it on the Russian yeah I
wonder if Trump noticed tomorrow voters
in states across the nation will head to
the polls for Super Tuesday not super
Thursday oh he said super Thursday you
can't do these things he's constantly
naming the wrong State
it's great to be in the state of Ohio no
no no I'm sorry you're in North Carolina
I honestly don't think he knows what
office he's running for they're gonna
put him into a home and other people are
gonna be running the country and they're
gonna be super left radical crazies now
everyone makes gaffes but Joe's multiply
faster than rabbits and while sometimes
Trump's words are shocking they don't
hint at an underlying decline Biden's
reminds you that he's not getting any
younger let alone wiser and it makes you
wonder what the endorsements from Amy
Pete and bado really mean is Joe leading
a parade of enthusiastic support or is
this a gurney race to push Joe across
the finish line on a stretcher
he faces a bigger challenge though he is
a moderate by today's loony left
standards but his one and only idea is
get rid of that orange meanie that's not
a vision that's a complaint meanwhile
Bernie's the outsider whose vision is
strong despite being wrong that's why he
attracts the youth the mad and the crazy
in a world where we idealize the bold a
radical is just sexier than a bumbling
moderate even a radical with your hair
it's not fair it's not smart but its
life maybe the Dems hadn't thrown all
their weight behind the fantasy of
impeachment they'd see this coming and
said the Dems are stuck with three
voting choices two cranky old men and
sleeping in I put my money on the snooze
button Dana Dana Dana what did we learn
from 2016 Rick Perry never start
something you can't finish remember
three things to say I have some things
so never start never start a really
famous quote if you don't if you can't
nail the quote that's kind of hard if
you can't nail the quote get off the
boat it is what a trey Gowdy on Saturday
night said sometimes it's like watching
a chain smoker fill up his gas tank I
think yeah it's concerning right and I
would imagine that his campaign is like
wow if we're really gonna be the
front-runner can he handle it yeah
that's a lot of energy now winning
sometimes gives you a pep in your step
but the other thing is about Joe Biden
it's like people seem to think it's
charming and they get it it's like oh
you men Thursday's I think they're super
forgiving yes gasps I think so too
because we all have somebody like that
in our lives Jesse you were my job every
day you say something that I go oh thank
you
[Laughter]
pulled the plug on the quote because he
didn't want to say under God in front of
a Democratic audience he said that was
maybe the smartest thing joe biden said
in the very long time but listen Bernie
Sanders is a mess I don't think even
Bernie knows if he could run the country
Bernie is like a heckler at a game that
just yells out you bum man you don't
make the heckler the manager you just
give the guy popcorn and pat him on the
head this guy knows he can't win and
everybody knows is not he's not so you
can't blame the Democratic Party for
rigging it against him if I was a
Democrat I'd rigged the heck out of this
thing you don't want the guy anywhere
near the White House meanwhile Joe Biden
is less coherent than crazy Bernie and
he can't even survive a good news cycle
without racking up gas he doesn't know
where he is what numbers are coming out
of his mouth who he's even talking to
it's a lackluster candidate with a bad
campaign I've never seen a Joe Biden
bumper sticker have any of you I've
never seen a Joe Biden crowd I mean he
can't get through an interview the guy
is slow and he's slowing down and it's
not a good look for Joe but the good
news is we get to watch the whole thing
unfold and it's a beautiful thing ah
what do you think Amy P
and bado were promised anything could
this be a quid pro quo cubed I think I
think you guys should stay away from
quid pro quos I think we heard a lot
about that with mr. Trump in the Ukraine
yeah but I think Amy Klobuchar said
explicitly that she was promised nothing
that she that she just wanted to do this
then she felt it was the right thing to
do in order to unify the party and
prepare them to defeat Donald Trump I
will say this I'm struck that President
Trump and clearly your delight in these
gaffes indicate again Republicans are
most worried about Joe Biden they don't
want to run against and that's why the
president sent Rudy to the Ukraine to
dig up dirt on guess who Joe Biden and I
have the feeling that hunter Biden's
name is gonna bubble up any second I see
already that in Congress there's
planning more hearings I think that what
the right wing is intent on is they like
to mock Joe Biden but I got to tell you
again Democrats do I'm gonna use Dana's
word think that it's charming that he is
authentic right that's something you
value greatly Jesse that he's authentic
he's real he's someone that you can
touch and know and he can touch you and
and it's also it's also the case I think
very clearly that it's not just my
opinion cuz what happened what do we see
in the polls especially post South
Carolina Democrats don't care about this
stuff it's Republicans who care about it
because they want you know the bullying
the mocking the berate ya know Democrats
are pointing this out okay well okay so
Joe Biden's appeal at this point has
been that he's the Statesman he's the
guy who's been in Washington for decades
so he knows what he's doing and you can
trust him to be someone who's reliable
to be a commander-in-chief and when he
continually looks incompetent with basic
things when it comes to a one-on-one
matchup with Donald Trump is going to
have a hard time trying to make the case
to people throughout the country who are
liking the economy who think that
President Trump has done a decent job
who think he's a competent
commander-in-chief Joe Biden is going to
have a very hard time doing that when it
comes to Bernie Sanders I think that
he's a threat as well I don't think you
can underestimate where he's going to go
be were to win the nomination which is
looking more like Convention as we go
into tonight but the coalition that he
has
coming out of Nevada is one that
Republicans are looking at Latinos young
women young people and if the whole
Democratic establishment would get
behind him he certainly would have more
of a machine than he does right now so I
wouldn't underestimate his ability and
the Trump campaigns research on him as
well they're probably doing a lot on
both Biden and Bernie Sanders okay then